this weekend is the unofficial start of
summer and founders coffee is here with
a few special summertime treats let's
welcome into the kitchen this is susie
newman the founders coffee toast expert
welcome to the show thank you what kind
of summer toast treats do you have for
us this stuff looks delicious by the way
what do you have for us here today we
have some fruit toast so we have
strawberry nutella blueberries and cream
banana foster
so really good for just like a summer
treat fruity yeah it's a breakfast in
itself too yeah it is it's i mean
healthy it's hell yes when it comes to
if someone's watching right now they
want to make this at home what's the
preferred toast that we're using we're
doing a multi-grain
is that your go-to at founders is the
multi-grain we do a multi-grain
a staple okay let's show you let's show
everyone some of the magic here so we
have a piece of your toast here what do
you put on it first well you're gonna
choose okay you can make your own toast
so we have nutella or honey cream cheese
i'm gonna go with honey cream cheese low
in calories right
and these this is everything is how it
works at founders i walk in and i can
make a custom order um i mean you could
pick a toast and then kind of customize
it add some different fruit if you
wanted to
or some different like coconut if you
wanted to okay so nice little spread
there what's next
now you can pick a fruit so we have
strawberries banana or blueberries
what are some of the uh
obviously coffee goes well with this but
what are some other drinks that you
recommend to go with your extravagant
toast we have the tea flight so this is
a seasonal flight and we only offer the
tea flight about once a year like for
three months tell me more about what's
in the seasonal tea flavor so we have a
sparkling strawberry kiwi we have a
blood orange tea spritz a watermelon
palmer and then a peach mint tea what's
a watermelon palmer what's that so it's
going to be uh watermelon syrup lemonade
tea and then tahin rim this is the one
right here i see the tea and why tahini
because of the spice it pops yeah is
this extra flavor are you watching what
i'm doing i don't know what i'm doing
this is the professional stuff and this
is the jc mix right here i'm just
throwing stuff on top of my toast what
is this coconut coconut coconut
mm-hmm
and what we call this
blueberry you would call this something
amazing very crunchy the jc amazing
crunch special uh i noticed too there's
breakfast sandwiches you guys have
breakfast oh so we have the chris uh
croissant chicken salad croissant
sandwich and then the breakfast burrito
which is so good my favorite is the
breakfast burrito how many locations in
town so we have two one on saint rose
and amigo and one on durango and sunset
open seven days a week
yep this is the perfect summertime treat
this is awesome thank you so much for
joining us i'm gonna take a bite of this
and rocky send it over to you
all right um let me make sure i'm on
the screen this is delicious